y
[Música]
traición así fue como francia calificó
del pacto o cruce entre eeuu reino unido
y australia con el que se entregara a
camberra submarinos de propulsión
nuclear china por su parte acusó a los
firmantes de fomentar una carrera
armamentística
protestas en argentina mientras aumenta
la atención dentro del gobierno el
presidente alberto fernández se envió un
directo mensaje a la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner
asegurando que no podrá obligarlo con
presiones esto luego de que varios
funcionarios kirchneristas presentaran
su renuncia
continúa la polémica respecto a los
escritores colombianos que no fueron
invitados a la feria del libro de madrid
pese a que colombia es el invitado de
honor el embajador en la capital
española aseguró que los seleccionados
para participar son autores neutros lo
que encendió aún más las críticas
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos esta
emisión de noticias con la indignación
de francia frente al nuevo acuerdo de
cooperación militar en el intro pacífico
entre australia eeuu y reino unido el
gobierno galo lo catalogó de traición
con la alianza de los australianos
cancelaron un contrato de compra de
submarinos por varios billones de euros
desde beijing aseguraron que el pacto
atenta contra la seguridad de la región
nadal ya plazas tiene los detalles
había sido calificado en su momento como
el contrato del siglo y su ruptura
repentina supone un nuevo golpe para
francia que hace apenas tres meses ya
había perdido un contrato para vender
aviones rafael a suiza que prefirió los
f-35 estadounidenses el ministro francés
de exteriores denunció el acuerdo hocus
con el que eeuu y reino unido- proveerán
a australia con nueva tecnología en
busca de limitar el auge de china en el
indo-pacífico simon beaufoy se
acordó
realmente es una puñalada por la espalda
construimos una relación de confianza
con australia que fue traicionada
esto no se hace en realidad esta
decisión abrupta e impredecible se
parece mucho de lo que hacía don al
trabajo invisible sabes
washington el acuerdo de 40.000 millones
de dólares con la empresa estatal
francesa naval group fue alcanzado en
2016 durante el gobierno de françois
hollande y había sido reconfirmado hace
tan sólo dos semanas
éste preveía fabricar 12 submarinos para
australia una flota que ahora será
construida por estados unidos con
tecnología de propulsión nuclear por su
parte la unión europea dijo no haber
sido informada del acuerdo e insistió
nuevamente en fortalecer su
independencia militar
es una buena oportunidad para recordar
para reflexionar sobre la necesidad de
plantear la cuestión de la autonomía
estratégica europea de gic europea
entretanto china rechazó la alianza que
tachó de irresponsable autoridad para la
cooperación de eeuu el reino unido y
australia en submarinos nucleares
daña gravemente la paz y la estabilidad
regional
intensifica la carrera armamentística y
pone en peligro los esfuerzos regionales
para promover la no proliferación de
armas nucleares
a todo esto australia dijo que había
tomado su decisión pensando en la mejor
forma de proteger a sus intereses por su
parte de eeuu defendió el pacto y
rechazó las críticas de china y francia
a la vez que aclaró no estar buscando
conflicto con beijing
hablamos ahora de afganistán el
secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio guterres fue contundente sobre
el limitado papel que tiene el organismo
a la hora de resolver los problemas que
enfrenta esa nación un mes después de la
conquista talibán miles de afganos están
al borde de un dramático desastre
humanitario según dijo el funcionario y
la situación continúa agravándose marina
sardiña nos amplía
un mes después de la toma del país por
el grupo talibán afganistán está sumido
en la incertidumbre sobre el rumbo que
tomará el nuevo gobierno de los
fundamentalistas que no cuenta con el
respaldo de occidente el secretario
general de naciones unidas alertó de un
dramático desastre humanitario pero
reconoció las limitaciones del organismo
para negociar con los talibanes
creo que hay una expectativa infundada
tenemos una serie de países que han
utilizado cientos de miles de soldados
durante décadas que han gastado billones
durante décadas trillions
y pensar que aunque hayan fracasado para
arreglar los problemas de afganistán
afganistán
con todos esos recursos la onu puede
ahora sin ese dinero y sin esas fuerzas
resolver esos problemas que no
resolvieron durante décadas es por
supuesto una fantasía is of course gente
si esta semana varios países prometieron
más de 1100 millones en ayuda
humanitaria que según guterres debe
usarse como instrumento para convencer a
los talibanes de que respeten los
derechos humanos el programa mundial de
alimentos 14 millones de afganos están
al borde de la inanición muchos
hospitales ya están viendo el aumento de
casos de desnutrición en menores
especialmente en las zonas rurales
los casos están aumentando día a día
y cuando comparamos con el año pasado
ese orden y porcentajes de desnutridos
es mayor y cosas así no da nada
además los pacientes en áreas muy
remotas de los distritos de otras
provincias vienen a nosotros under
formen sescam en atrás más de la mitad
de la población afgana ya dependía de
las donaciones extranjeras muchas
suspendidas con la toma talibán
agravando la crisis económica que
amenaza con sumir al 97% de la población
en la pobreza vamos a américa latina en
argentina miles de ciudadanos
protestaron en las calles de buenos
aires tras la derrota del oficialismo en
las elecciones primarias del pasado
domingo la manifestación se produce
mientras continúa aumentando la atención
dentro del gobierno en medio de la
profunda división entre el presidente
alberto fernández y la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner el
mandatario aseguró que la gestión del
ejecutivo continuará desarrollándose
como él lo considere conveniente en
declaraciones a un medio nacional
resaltó que no cederá a las presiones
luego de que varios funcionarios del
kirchnerismo presentarán su renuncia
ella me conoce sabe que por las buenas a
mí me sacan cualquier cosa con presiones
no me van a obligar
previamente desde buenos aires nuestro
corresponsal natalio coso y nos contó
los detalles más recientes en esta
confrontación
lo más reciente lo más urgente es que
cristina fernández después de muchas
horas muchas muchas horas más de un día
de silencio publicó una carta pública
abierta en su sitio web en su blog en la
que dice algunas cosas muy fuertes dice
que en numerosas reuniones con el
presidente señale que creía que se
estaba llevando a cabo una política de
ajuste fiscal equivocada que estaba
impactando negativamente en la actividad
económica y de dice también en la carta
que ella insistía en que eso llevaría a
perder en las elecciones también dice
que una vez que se perdió cree que los
funcionarios deberían haber puesto la
renuncia esa disposición y le pide al
presidente que relanza su gobierno y
algo muy importante para que entienda al
público en otros países que no son
argentinas cristina fernández de
kirchner le recuerda en la carta que fue
ella la que lo postuló como presidente y
ella como vice de cara a las elecciones
de 2019 porque ella a pesar de tener
muchos votos de contar con muchos votos
de la población no tenía votos
suficientes para llegar a ganar esa
elección en 2019 entonces se conformó
esta coalición peronista que hoy está en
crisis con alberto fernández como
presidenta y ella como vice
en medio de los festejos por los 211
años de la independencia de mexico el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
le pidió a su homólogo estadounidense
joe biden que ponga fin al bloqueo que
washington mantiene sobre cuba las
declaraciones del mandatario se
produjeron en presencia del jefe de
estado de la isla miguel díaz canel
invitado especial de obrador a las
celebraciones las palabras se producen
en la víspera de la cumbre de la
comunidad de estados latinoamericanos y
caribeños celac que se celebrará este
sábado en ciudad de mexico
ojalá que el presidente va a ir
quien posee
suficiente sensibilidad política
actúe
con esa grandeza
y ponga fin
para siempre a la política
de agravios hacia cuba'' y hay polémica
en colombia luego de que reconocidos
autores no fueran invitados a participar
en la feria del libro de madrid que este
año exalta a ese país como invitado de
honor todos los excluidos son contrarios
al gobierno del presidente iván duque y
al ser cuestionado al respecto el
embajador de colombia en la capital
española aseguró que habían invitado a
escritores neutros entre los excluidos
se encuentran autores de la talla de
laura restrepo héctor abad faciolince
fernando vallejo y piedad bonnett con
quien conversamos hace unos momentos y
la preguntamos qué opina de este
calificativo de neutros para los
invitados
bueno yo creo que el embajador fue muy
torpe
digamos mostró un gran desconocimiento
al emplear esa palabra por pero también
mostró
al gobierno lo que le interesa es todo
lo que sea neutro lo que no sea
beligerante lo que no sea contestatario
y yo entiendo la palabra neutro como
algo ni fú-ni fá es decir muy poco
relevante muy gris muy sin conflicto
incluido pero además me pareció un
insulto con la gente que estaba allá
entre la cual hay que decir que hay
gente muy buena y muy reconocida
entonces que les pusiera el mote de
neutro me me pareció un una ofensa
analistas colombianos aseguraron que
excluir a escritores tan importantes
haría que en la feria quedara una visión
incompleta de la realidad nacional esto
es lo que ella opina al respecto
parece que en la feria si hay gente
representativa de otras etnias digamos
de que
hay una mujer del choco que es una
cantaora que es una en lo que vi hay
gente muy joven o sea hay una cierta
representatividad
no me puse a mirar cuánta gente de
provincia cuánta del centro no me
interesa sí pero
pero por supuesto que es que no hay un
equilibrio eso es lo que tal vez estamos
diciendo no hay un equilibrio no sobre
todo lo que no hay valentina es
representatividad de los escritores que
estamos publicados por las editoriales
españolas y que desde hace muchos años
somos leídos por los lectores españoles
en una feria donde los escritores
tenemos contacto directo con el público
esa es una falencia pero también nos
compartió su visión sobre si la
selección de autores invitados tiene
algún tinte político de parte del
gobierno de bandos
pues es que eso creo que fue lo que se
reveló lo que yo he dicho es no es que
nosotros seamos
contestatarios del gobierno a través de
nuestras obras porque la literatura no
no funciona así la buena literatura 9 ni
panfletaria ni discursiva ni ni ataca a
un gobierno en particular
pero nosotros muchos nos hemos expresado
a través de las columnas oa través de
las entrevistas como personas con
discrepancias profundas
sobre este gobierno y sobre el manejo
por ejemplo de las del orden público y
sobre muchas otras cosas entonces yo
creo que ellos le temían más a las
entrevistas con los periodistas que a
los libros mismos que fuéramos a
presentar allá
y en nicaragua que también conmemora su
independencia de españa el gobierno de
daniel ortega decidió enviar a cientos
de estudiantes a festejos patrios
durante este mes pese al grave repunte
de casos de kobe 19 en esa nación jorge
hurtado nos detalla cómo vive en el
bicentenario en nicaragua
un festejo patriótico a lo grande el
gobierno de nicaragua invitó a sus
ciudadanos a reunirse por todo el país
con motivo del bicentenario de la
independencia de españa y pese a un
repunte de qom y 19 la pandemia no nos
ha dejado tregua sin embargo esto no
podemos nosotros dejar de celebrar una
fecha tan histórica como esta este país
atraviesa una grave crisis social
económica y política en medio de una
oleada de arrestos a opositores de cara
a unas elecciones en las que daniel
ortega busca un cuarto período
presidencial
es mi primera vez sinceramente de salir
en la financia
pero 300 estudiantes porque lo que se
tiene que tomar en las medidas de
bioseguridad porque lo más importante es
lo que está orientando nuestro gobierno
ahora a cuidarlo
costa rica donde se han refugiado la
mayoría de opositores nicaragüenses el
político enrique sáenz señala que estos
festejos obedecen a una estrategia
política conocida como 'pan y circo' en
la antigüedad las dictaduras no tienen
imaginación y repiten lo que otros
dictadores han hecho en otros tiempos no
sólo en la época contemporánea sino que
esto de 'pan y circo' viene desde los
romanos
así es que lo que pretenden es aplicar
este tipo de políticas para distraer la
atención sobre todo de la juventud y
nicaragua los festejos patrios fueron
acompañados por 10 días de vacaciones a
los trabajadores del estado y
estudiantes así como la exoneración de
impuestos al sector turismo gracias por
acompañarnos en esta emisión recuerden
que pueden ampliar todas las noticias y
repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom regresamos
en momentos con más información aquí en
france 24
[Música]